Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
El ruido constante
por debajo de tus pies,
el espacio limitado,
y la monotonía de ir a ninguna parte.
Parece que han pasado horas, pero
solo han transcurrido 11 minutos,
y te preguntas:
"¿Por qué me estoy torturando?
Esta cosa debe considerarse
un castigo cruel e inusual".
En realidad, eso es exactamente
lo que es o era.
En el 1800
las cintas se crearon para castigar
a los prisioneros ingleses.
Por aquel entonces, el sistema inglés
penitenciario era extremadamente malo.
La ejecución y la deportación eran
a menudo los castigos empleados
y los prisioneros enfrentaban horas
de soledad en celdas inmundas.
Movimientos sociales liderados por grupos
religiosos, organizaciones filantrópicas,
y celebridades, como Charles Dickens,
intentaron
cambiar esas condiciones calamitosas
para así ayudar a reformar a los presos.
Cuando su movimiento tuvo éxito,
cárceles enteras fueron remodeladas
y nuevas formas de rehabilitación,
tales como la cinta de correr,
se introdujeron.
Así es cómo funcionaba
la versión original inventada en 1818
por el ing. inglés Sir William Cubitt.
Los prisioneros entraban en 24 radios
de una gran rueda de paletas.
Mientras la rueda giraba,
el prisionero estaba obligado a mantener
la intensidad por el riesgo de caerse,
similar a las máquinas
caminadoras modernas.
Mientras tanto, la rotación hacía mover
el engranaje para bombear agua,
moler grano.
o mover molinos,
lo que originó el nombre en inglés
de "treadmill" [molino de pasos].
Esos dispositivos se veían como una forma
fantástica de azotar a los prisioneros
cuyo beneficio de accionar molinos
ayudaba a reconstruir
una economía británica diezmada
por las guerras napoleónicas.
una victoria para todos los interesados,
a excepción de los prisioneros.
Se estima que, en promedio,
los prisioneros pasaban seis o más horas
al día en cintas de correr,
el equivalente a subir
entre 1500 y 4000 metros.
4000 m es más o menos la mitad
del camino al Monte Everest.
Imagínate haciendo eso los cinco días
de la semana comiendo poco.
La idea de Cubitt se extendió rápidamente
por todo el Imperio Británico y EE.UU.
En una década de su creación,
más de 50 prisiones inglesas
usaba una cinta de correr,
y en EE.UU. una cantidad similar.
Como era de esperar, el ejercicio
combinado con la mala nutrición
supuso que muchos reclusos sufrían
colapsos y lesiones,
lo que a los guardias de la prisión
no parecía importar.
En 1824 el guardián de la prisión
de Nueva York, James Hardie, decía
del dispositivo con el que domesticaba
a sus presos más bulliciosos que
la "firmeza monótona y no su gravedad
es lo que conforma el terror".
una cita con la que muchos
todavía están de acuerdo.
Y las cintas caminadoras perduraron
en Inglaterra hasta el siglo XIX,
hasta que fueron prohibidos
por ser excesivamente crueles
bajo la Ley de 1898 de la prisión.
Pero, el dispositivo de tortura
volvió como una venganza,
esta vez dirigido al público desprevenido.
En 1911 fue registrada una patente
para una cinta de correr en los EE.UU.,
y en 1952 se creó el precursor para
la cinta de correr moderna de hoy.
Cuando la locura de correr golpeó
a los EE.UU. en la década de 1970,
la cinta volvió de nuevo
a ser protagonista
como una manera fácil y conveniente
para mejorar la capacidad aeróbica,
y perder kilos no deseados,
que, para ser justos,
es muy bueno hacerlo.
Y la máquina ha mantenido
su popularidad desde entonces.
Así que la próxima vez que
voluntariamente te sometas a lo que
fuera una vez un castigo cruel e inusual,
alégrate de que puedas controlar
subir y bajar de ella.